جوعتونا من الصبح نتائج صادمه لاستطلاع
اثاره غضبا عارما بين دعاه المساواه بين
الرجال
والنساء في المانيا حيث راى ثلث الشباب
الالمان انهم من المقبول استخدام
العنف ضد المراه الحقيقه يعني شيء مفاجئ
الفعل ولكن الاستطلاع اجرته منظمه الاطفال
الخيريه بلان انترناشونال
ونشرت نتائجه بالفعل في او نتائجه في
الصحف المحليه في الاستطلاع اعترف 34% من
الرجال بارتكابهم اعمال عنف تجاهه شركات
حياتهم في الماضي من اجل غرس الاحترام في
نفوسهم واقلها 33% انهم يعتقدون انه من
المقبول الاعتداء باليد على شركاتهم من
حين لاخر اثناء الجدال
بالفعل انه يعني
الرجل حينما يعتدي على الامراه يتزوج
عليها معلش بس يعتدي على
فكره انه بعتقد بانه هي دراسه كتير مفاجئه
لا دوله مثل المانيا بالفعل يعني ولكن
يعني هي ايضا تعتمد على على الشقوط وعلى
الشريحه وعلى نتائجها يعني معرض لمثل هذا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات